hi guys so I have been saving up for an
electric ukulele for a very very long
time this is mainly because I really
want to get involved in more open mic
nights and gigs and things like that and
at the moment with an acoustic ukulele
it's a little bit difficult to the point
where I've had to have people hold an
extra mic it is finally time for me to
open a box that I have been waiting for
for the longest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this crazy
TomTom
[Music]
I've seen those uses they're very pretty
[Music]
pretty
[Music]
so we call them the mahogany tattoo
series and it's electric and it looks so
damn pretty and it comes with Aquila
string which was a massive selling
quickly
[Music]
[Music]
I yelled Hades he didn't like this maybe
a party talk to me all you ladies if
you're feeling like this move your body
don't stop so mister right now do it
like that
just like my back my cat it's makes
wider neck why I beg it is part of
coming but it's okay to me no to me okay
this ukulele is a lunar concert ukulele
and concert means it's a little bit
bigger than my original one so this is
the new one that I have just unboxed in
the most delightful way this is part of
the lunar mahogany series it has Aquila
strings already attached to it which are
great because the koala strings in my
opinion the best strings that you can
buy for ukuleles here is my old one and
as you can see there's a little bit of
height difference just like me and all
of my friends because I'm so tiny so
this is a soprano and this is a concert
and the concerts play a little bit
louder anyway so that's good I mean I
can have a little a little play for you
[Music]
beautiful
yeah not much different than the pitch
but it is slightly lower pitched and it
is electric so it does have a built-in
pickup and preamp side it has a little
battery check so you can see it already
came fully charged which is brilliant I
still need to buy a little amp and some
cables for it but I'm pretty excited to
use the electric functions and see how
that sound it does come with a bag as I
showed you but I'll still be using my
other bag because my other bag is
awesome wait let me get it there phew
this bag basically represents me it is
me in bag form that's just an angry
little bag so yeah that's pretty much my
name you clearly I just wanted to have
some fun and run around in the field and
play ukulele in a box
[Music]
but honestly thank you so much thank you
thank you thank Nicky have a lovely day
or evening bye oh one extra thing the
winner has been announced from the
flippin death video a few weeks back if
you had applied to that competition and
left a comment on that video then check
your email because you might have
something for me camera lady
if I'm tangling herself what she does
for me
I'm the best shaky cam okay
together we will take your two best are
together we will gain no subscribers
lose them all but have all of the
contents you'll see Pippa jackin sov
enough